a British newspaper is reporting the FBI
is now looking into how it can interview
Britain's Prince Andrew over his
relationship with Jeffrey Epstein Queen
Elizabeth's second son is already facing
consequences within the royal household
Roxana Saberi is following the story
from Buckingham Palace Roxana what is
the latest this morning good morning CBS
News has learned Prince Andrew was
stepping inside from all the charities
he's involved in at least for now it
appears to be a drastic move but one
aimed at stopping those organizations
from distancing themselves from him so
far the palace won't comment on whether
the FBI is trying to interview him would
you be willing to testify or give a
statement under oath if you were asked
well I'm like everybody else and I would
have to take all the legal advice that
there was before I was to do that sort
of thing battling backlash after this
BBC interview more than a week ago
Prince Andrew has since said he'll
cooperate with law enforcement agencies
investigating his late friend convicted
sex offender Jeffrey Epstein
now the FBI reportedly wants to
interview him well correspondent Ryan
Nieto we understand that the FBI looking
for ways to speak to him in Britain
through the US Justice Department to see
logistical ehad that could be done and
sources Clayton French on pins Andrew
have said he'd be happy to do that the
news comes as Buckingham Palace
confirmed Prince Andrew is temporarily
standing back from the more than 230
charities he's involved in several
organizations like the English National
Ballet and the Royal Philharmonic
Orchestra had already cut ties with him
Queen Elizabeth has not commented
publicly on the scandal on Friday she
was spotted horseback riding with Prince
Andrew in what was seen as a public show
of support but now she's reportedly
cancelled a big party she'd planned to
host in February for his 60th birthday
privately she's you know she's
supporting him he's her son but you know
she's pretty frustrated that this has
been overshadowing a huge amount of
other members of the royal family the
work they're doing
one British tabloid the Sun is reporting
that the princess friend ghilane Maxwell
will speak with the FBI about their ties
to Epstein the two famously appear in a
photo with one of Epstein's accusers
Tony Roxanna in London for us Roxanna
thank you very much